worthy Avengers we can bust arms dealers
all the live long day but that up there
that's that's saying a game how are you
guys planning on beating them together
hey everybody is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of New Avengers endgame to break
down we got a better look at all their
new costumes and a bunch of confirmed
cameos we'll do a new brand of that
Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video uh name a new
winner at the end of this so first big
thing
Catherine Langford is apparently ginger
in Avengers end game we have a better
look at Pepper Potts new blue rescue
armor Valkyrie is confirmed to be coming
back the Chitauri confirmed to be coming
back and we have alternate prototypes of
all the Avengers new matching white
suits although when you look at these
they look a little bit more like silver
on black so not necessarily white I'm
guessing that these white ones are just
prototypes and these are the finished
ones because you actually see them on
shelves in a store with packaging the
only minor differences between them are
that Thor and Hulk have giant shoulder
pieces because obviously they're so much
bigger they would need stronger costumes
if you zoom and enhance here you'll
notice that they have those special
wrist devices that we've been talking
about also go back around to that in a
second but if you're wondering where all
this stuff came from someone in Vietnam
apparently was able to walk into a store
and buy a bunch of these off the shelf
that's the currency there V&E they're
all about the same price this is about
seventeen American dollars after you
convert currencies so I'm assuming
you'll see these in stores around the
rest of the world when we get a little
bit closer to endgame actually coming
out they usually start selling toys in
advance of a movie you also notice that
Black Widows new longer haircut is
confirmed by all the different photos
we've seen of her for the past couple of
months
she's onset here with the longer hair
and in all these pictures it just looks
like she stops dying it lets her natural
red hair grow out but the tips are still
a little blonde from when she used to
diet this also confirms what Kevin Feige
said a little while ago when he said we
only be getting Avengers endgame trailer
footage from about the first 20 minutes
of the film he said this relatively
accurate so we will probably see a
couple things from later in the film
questions I know you can bat off very
easily but the menders endgame we now
know the title how long did we did you
know the title was this high
in place during production it was in
place before that before we started
developing the movie or just as we were
developing it yes
so dr. strange says that line because we
knew it was the title there's talk that
in the marketing of it that real I
obviously seen the first trailer which
presumably doesn't show us much at all
that in the market and you're never
gonna show us much past say the first 15
or 20 minutes of the movie is that kind
of strategy is that somewhat accurate I
call it somewhat accurate yeah I think I
think as was the case with a lot of our
films this one in particular you know
being able to generate excitement
without giving away any of the many many
many many when you hear the press
talking about 15 to 20 minutes that's
just everyone interpreting his reaction
here but he does pause for a second as
if ya know we'll probably see a couple
things from later in the film but for
the most part the next trailer that we
see will still probably be from
relatively early in the film you may
have also seen the news that the Black
Widow movie is now confirmed to be
shooting sometime at the end of February
for a May 2020 beliefs date word is now
that Black Widow will be May 20 2010
there's a November 2020 movie that
Marvel is releasing that will wind up
being the Eternals film because they're
still in pre-production on that we'll
probably hear a little bit more about
that this summer
guardians 3 was originally supposed to
come out July 2020 but that's been
postponed indefinitely and in that same
interview clip that I had of Kevin Feige
earlier he also said they were
definitely doing guardians 3 but they're
not ready to talk about when that's
going to happen like what you're
thinking you're gonna do with that in
terms of finding another director and
I'm curious also like thoughts on James
potentially getting into the DC Universe
is that bittersweet for you you know I
would see Aquaman last night and I
really really enjoyed it so and you know
me I've always supported I don't see a
rivalry I see coole films being made and
James Scott one thing you know about
James Gunn he makes cool films guardians
will happen when where how for a later
time other really good Marvel phase 4
news is they confirm the Doctor Strange
sequel they're going to start
pre-production on that soon but at the
rate they're going it probably won't
come out before 2021 some of the figures
come with weapons some of them don't it
looks like Thor doesn't have his
original hammer or storm breaker but
that just might be because they didn't
want to include it with the toy because
it would cost more money Thanos has his
original armor from an infinity war like
we've seen in all the pictures and the
sword which we've also seen and all the
concept art so far the Ronin Hawkeye 1
is probably one of the more important
ones because it labels his toy as Ronin
not Hawkeye and you get a much better
rendering of what his costume looks like
from the front it's obviously just the
comic book Ronin costume toned down a
little bit Captain America is in his
scale armor from the comics with his new
shield it looks like they're just
repackaging the old spider-man iron
spider star-lord in Black Panther toys
from infinity war in the Black Panther
movie like just taking the toys out of
those boxes that they sold for those
films and putting them in new boxes on
the shelf next to these New Avengers
endgame toys they do that all the time
for movies just in the name of selling
more toys all you do is you put an old
toy in a brand new box pretty easy to
assume why they don't have new costumes
just because they aren't featured that
prominently during avengers endgame the
ruse has already told us that most of
the characters that were snapped in
Avengers infinity war would not be
featured as much in Avengers and game
with a couple of exceptions like Gamora
who's still a really important character
in people like Doctor Strange mostly all
in favor of focusing on the core
original Avengers but because they had
to give arch to all these different
characters between two films they just
decided to split the focus so they could
at least give everyone some good scenes
that's why we didn't get a ton of
Captain America scenes during infinity
war because he's opening what seems like
avengers endgame starting this big
mission I don't know what we're gonna do
if this doesn't work while Ironman is
trapped in deep space trying to get back
it's an old message of all the original
Avengers during Avengers endgame Iron
Man in Captain America's arcs are
probably the most important for obvious
reasons they're both at the end of their
contracts in real life but Marvel and
Kevin Feige have put their relationship
at the center of the Avengers storyline
ever since that first Avengers film
they're like the heart and soul of the
Avengers for those of you asking about
the ginger version of Catherine Lankford
here most people I've seen on the
Internet are taking this as confirmation
that she's the
water of Iron Man and Pepper Potts
because ginger like just ginger for
Pepper Potts why would you cast someone
notable like Catherine Langford then
change her natural brunette to ginger if
she wasn't going to be tied to Pepper
Potts in some way the hairstyle doesn't
necessarily confirm that she is their
daughter but there's only a couple of
ways that that could work in the movie
if it's true one if there's legit time
travel through the quantum realm - if
she's a computer-generated
extrapolation of what their daughter
might look like in the future like a
reverse ba are effing technology like
you use that technology to look into the
past through your memories but you can
also extrapolate like based on our
genetic code this is what our daughter
might look like or 3 if she's from an
alternate reality where Iron Man and
Pepper Potts settled down a long time
ago but she looks kind of like she's in
her mid-20s like Catherine Lankford is
you know early mid-20s actor so it
doesn't really seem possible because
Pepper Potts right now in the MCU is 46
years old so unless she and Tony in an
alternate reality had a child when she
was in her like really early 20s like
surprise baby then if Catherine Langford
really is their daughter from the future
it just screams time-travel there's also
supposedly a version of teenage Cassie
Lang stature from Young Avengers rumored
in the film played by this actress but
we'll see because right now that's still
just a rumor the Chitauri coming back
I'm assuming is probably from those
original Avengers scenes that they
reshot to make them look new because
they're walking around in their original
costumes and they're trying to find
something they probably shot some new
scenes from the original Battle of New
York to make it look like it was
happening way back during that original
battle and just had some other our
e running around during those all I can
really say about Valkyrie at this point
is that it would make sense that they
would cameo her in the film aside from
core
she's like the most important and
Asgardian character to Thor who's still
confirmed alive as a present-day so if
you're still wondering what happened to
her at the end of Thor Ragnarok before
the beginning of infinity war the way
the Russos in the writers explain it is
that she and cork were able to escape
off the ship before Thanos arrived and
save a portion of that Asgardian
population so there are still a couple
Asgardians out there Valkyrie just being
one of the more important ones to Thor
I've already talked about the Pepper
Potts rescue armor a pretty
self-explanatory
Nitori if you've ever read the Iron Man
comics her rescue armor looks a little
bit more like Iron Man's in that they're
probably just coloring this blue so that
you can tell them apart on screen for
people that do not read the comics like
oh that's pepper flying over there
saving people this is Iron Man over here
saving these people I'm just expecting
her to get like a really badass scene
where she rescues people see what they
did there there's just a more upgraded
badass version of her wearing the armor
during Iron Man 3 and it's a lot of fun
to see pepper and Tony team up in a
great sort of old-fashioned action movie
way
I didn't mind wearing the suit at all I
thought it was light and perfectly
comfortable and my children thought I
was extremely cool
I don't wanna stay here a lot of you saw
the spider-man far from home trailer and
you're like wait a minute why is Pepper
Potts and happy dealing with this why
isn't Iron Man's name signed on this
check here I think all this scene here
confirms is that she's still alive 1 & 2
still the CEO of Stark Industries and in
charge of Tony's charities and deciding
who gets what funding if you look at the
side of this check here it just reads
disaster relief so this is just iron man
using his own money to help clean up and
help New York City a lot people who lost
their homes to whatever a big battle
happens during avengers endgame so
circling back around to those special
risks devices because there's so many
questions about the plot twists of the
movie is it gonna be time travel is it
gonna be alternate realities because all
those things work when you talk about
the quantum realm and quantum energy the
reason why everyone's calling these
their quantum suits is because Thor and
Hulk don't need spacesuits they can
survive in the vacuum of space for a
good long while Thor was floating in
space before the Guardians picked him up
and he was hopping around on the Rings
in need of a year before he soaked that
giant blast from the star so if he can
survive that he can hang out in deep
space without a suit for a little while
but it seems like based on these
pictures from behind the scenes in their
original Avengers battle that the
quantum energy will have something to do
with those wristbands and them
travelling between different locations
and possibly times to find whatever it
is they need to defeat Thanos it all
just depends on what they use that
quantum energy for so let me know in the
comments what do you think about these
new suits and who do you think that
ginger Catherine Langford is playing in
the movie what'll happen is is there's a
whole bunch more spider-man and Captain
Marvel stuff they drop recently so I'll
try to make videos for all that stuff
congratulations Matthew Chu you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video click here to watch all the
alternate once upon a Deadpool
post-credit scenes and click here to
rewatch the spider-man far from home
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]